i'm leo you must be nancy may i come
inside yes
so i've made a list of things that i'd
like to get through number one
i perform oral sex on you number two you
perform oral sex on me number three we
do a 69 if that's what it's still called
um four me on top five doggy style
that all sounds very achievable i booked
enough time
you you want to do it all today
yes
no
i've never had an orgasm there are nuns
out there with more sexual experience
than me it's embarrassing drop me to
brush my teeth
oh god this is crazy it's terrible it's
wrong nancy yes come have a dance at me
i guess i'm frustrated
leo grant your real name i'm thinking
about all the places i should have been
by now i simply don't understand why
you're doing this this to save up for
our college oh how wonderful are you
really no
i've always been ashamed of my body your
body's beautiful i wish you could see
that
everyone wants something different i
don't judge my clients unless they're
total rehearsals
i've never done anything interesting in
my life
[Music]
you're the only adventure i've ever had
[Music]
what's the oldest person you've ever
done it with 82 82 yes 82 nancy okay i'm
feeling a bit better now
[Music]